[موسيقى]
ما وراء الافلام مع محمود النجار على
العربيه بودكاست
1996 فتحت التلفزيون يوم 10 مايو هتعرف
خبر كريزي وهو موت ثمانيه اشخاص على جبل
افرست بعد هبوب عاصفه غير متوقع في سنه
2015 قدر المخرج والكاتب سيمون
1953 وبعدها والمده 40 سنه ما حدش قادر
يوصل لقمه ايفرست وكان فيه محاولات فشله
جدا
سنه 1992 لما ظهر روبهال ووضع مفهوم ارشاد
البعثات التجاريه لمتسلق الجبال واللي كان
في بيهتم هولب اداء التفاصيل علشان
المتسلق يطلع الجبل وينزل بامان وفي خلال
اربع سنين بس قدر هو وفريقه ادفنشر كال
سانتس يرشده 19 مجموعه ويوصلهم بامان لقمه
الجبل من غير ما يحصل ولا وفاء واحده وفي
سنه 1996 الموضوع اتطور وبدا انتشار مفهوم
ارشاد البعثات التجاريه في الوقت ده و
خلال اسبوعين بس هيطلع اكثر من 20 بعث
لقمه ده اللي حصل في الحقيقه وده اللي
بيحكي عنه الفيلم وهنجح اغلبهم فعلا لكن
بسبب عاصفه مفاجاه الاوضاع بتتغير وبيموت
ثمان اشخاص من ضمنهم بالمناسبه الفيلم
الماخوز احداثه ومستاهلها من كتاب جون
كرافت الاكثر مبيعا انتم سن اير ماي جونير
وكان احد اجزاء فريق اللي عاشوا التجربه
بالكامل وكراكر كان احد الناجين فيدريوس
اللي حصل بالتفصيل في فيلم هيظهر
والموجوده في الحقيقه فخليني احكي لك عنها
منطقه الموت مصطلح عام بيستخدم الوصف في
منطقه في جبل بيزيد ارتفاعا عن 8000 متر
يعني تقريبا 26 الف قدم في الارتفاع ده
الجسم بيفقد القدره تماما على التاقلم
وبيبدا يموت مهما كانت تدريب اللي متسلق
مر به فما فيش انسان يقدر يعيش في منطقه
الموت اكثر من 48 ساعه من غير اكسجين
اضافي المنطقه دي موجوده في 14 جبل بس في
جميع انحاء العالم منهم جبل افرست مستوى
الاكسجين هناك تقريبا بيبقى ثلث القيمه
الموجوده عند مستوى سطح البحر يعني ببساطه
جسم الانسان بيستنفذ امدادات الاكسجين
الخاصه بشكل اسرع من تجديده وده بياثر على
حالته العقليه والجسديه فتلاقي متسلقين
كثير جدا بيصابه بالهلوسه وفقدان الوعي
وتدهور وظائف الجسم والشعور بالخنقه
الشديده وفي النهايه المنتدى للاسف وبسبب
منطقه الموت وبعد رحلات كثيره جدا للبحثين
وصل عدد الجثث في منطقه الموت في جبل
افرست ل 150 جثه موجوده هناك لحد يوم ده
وللاسف ما يقدروش يسترجعوها لان دي تعتبر
مهمه انتحاريا وزي ما في منطقه الموت في
منطقه قوس قزح وده اللي بيقع فيها متسلقين
المحكوم عليهم بالفنانات يعني اللي بيقعوا
في الصداع وبيتحنطوا من البرد بتكون
المنطقه دي اسفل القمه مباشره
ده بتكتشف انهيار جليدي في مكان قريب بس
في الحقيقه حياته بتستمر لان ربعها اللي
هينقذه جون كراكر مؤلف انتم ذابتين اير
بيقول ان بيك ودرز وساكو نامبا كانو
هيسقطوا اكثر من مره وهتنتهي حياتهم في
السبوع مشبه الموقف كان النمله غرقانه في
الدم فلك انت تخيل عزيزي المستمع حاله
النمله غرقانه في قمه جديده كل متسلق
بيبقى عنده حياته عنده اللي بيحبهم
وبيحبوه عنده مهنته اصلا وعنده احلام
واماله والناس اللي معتمد عليه في فيلم
ايفرست هتشوف ازاي ده كان سبب ان في ناس
منهم تنجح في الاصول القمه حتى لو هيكون
ده اخر حاجه
وهو بيتسلق وده بسبب امتداد الاشعه فوق
البنفسجيه وهو اصلا كان عامل عمليه في
القرنيه فبدل ما يطلع قرر في النهايه ينزل
لكن العاصفه بتهاجمه ويفقد ولما وصل
الاناث
والمتسلقه اليابانيه يا سوكو تقديم الوعي
تماما ومش هيتم انقاذهم في كل الظروف دي
فسبهم ماشيين ولما وصل ستيجورد تشيزون
واثنين من افراد شعب الشريع علشان يقيموا
حاله واتس فقدوا فيه الامل وقالوا انه
خلاص مات وبالفعل تم الاعلان ده وتذاع خبر
وفاهه لكن ده ما كانش حقيقي وودرس بيحكي
وبيقول سعيد في الثلج وفتحت عيني وكانت
ايدي اليمين مكشوفها بره الثالثه وكان
واضح انهامات تقريبا ما كنتش حاسس باي
انسجه في ايديا وفي مناخيري فتاكدت ان هو
متدمره من البروده وفي اللحظه دي واللي
فكرت فيها الناس تسلم
حريه ثانيه لطياره الهليكوبتر والطيارين
اللي هيروحوا ياخدوه في العاصفه دي وعلى
الرغم ان الفيلم ظهر الاحداث دي بسرعه جدا
وان مراته هتجيب طياره وتبعتها على الجبل
علشان تنقذ جوزها في الحقيقه كان الوضع
اصعب بكثير لان بيتش ووزرس لما عرفت ان
جوزها طلع عايش مش ميت كلمت كل اصحاب
علشان يساعدوها في توفيرها والموضوع وصل
ان هم اتصلوا بالسنتر الامريكي كايبلي من
تكساس وتوم داشلز زعيم الاقليات ديمقراطيه
في مجلس الشيوخ شجع داش وزاره الخارجيه
على تصرف بسرعه وفي النهايه يبعته
خليني اقول لك ان ده مش عادي باي شكل من
الاشكال ليه بقى لان في الوقت اللي بيحصل
فيه كل ده هو سنه 1961 الهلوكوبتر كانت
على ارتفاع اكثر من 19,000 و860 ودي اعلى
عمليه انقاذ تم انجازها على الاطلاق من
اعظم المواقف الانسانيه اللي حصلت وقتها
ان الطياره في الاساس كانت رايحه
لكن مقول جاو كانت حالته اسوا بكثير فقرر
ويترز وقتها يتخلى عن مكانه والماكوله وده
ما ظهرش في الفيلم الفيلم ظهر بس ان
الطياره جاءت وانقذت في الحقيقه وودز
بيحكي وبيقول اتسين لايك
طارق
هو كمان
اللي حصل سنه 1996 خلينا اقول لك ايوه
سنه 2014
وفي 2015 اتكرر لانهيار ده ومات 18 شخص
فيلم ايفرست حاول ينقل الجزء من اللي بيمر
به المتسلقين والصعوبات اللي بيوجوها
هتشوفهم وهما بيتدربوا وكمان هتشوفهم وهم
بيوصلوا للقمه وبيحتفلوا بانجازهم العظيم
ده لكن فعليا ما فيش حاجه وردي وكل خطوه
عظيمه لها جانب المظلم والمتعب بتاعها ده
كان ما وراء قصه بعثه ترابها وان قالها
فيلم ايفرست فخليني احكي لك عمار نفسه
الفيلم بطوله جاسم
البندقيه السينمائي الدولي الثاني سبتمبر
سنه 2015
سبتمبر سنه 2015
الحلقه اللي جايه في فيلم جديد في ما وراء
الافلام المقدم العربي والكسل
[موسيقى]